welcome to the princess of wales
theaters it's kind of coincidental oh
yeah i hadn't thought of that yeah yeah
so how does it feel to be premiering
this film in canada tonight uh great
i've never been to canada oh really no
never been here my little brother came
here
a few years ago and loved it so
it's nice yeah it's been great so far
i've only been here 24 hours and i'm
leaving in 24 hours
are you gonna squeeze in any little
sites before you go i don't know i don't
know i'm gonna have time but i'll
definitely come back and i'll do a
little visit yeah right right okay so
this film
rock star cast yeah you are partnered
with your again your friend olivia
coleman how is it working with her on
this film versus you know everyone's
favorite the crown well i i suppose it
was strange because we'd i mean it
wasn't that far off when we finished on
the season and
you know i saw i see her all the time so
it was kind of strange
it just felt like another day and we
didn't really i think i did one day with
collie with olivia on this and so it was
a
um
yeah i wish i'd had more i mean it's
like the dream to work with her i'd work
with her all the time if i could yeah of
course i mean queen on screen queen off
screen we love her um did you get a
chance to sort of chat with colin while
on set you know another
even a king on screen yeah it was the
first time i worked with colin
um and i love colin
and i hadn't like a sort of mild
competition with odessa who could
be colin's best friend oh i'd love it
it's ongoing actually mm-hmm i'm still
in the process of trying to win him over
so who's winning right now between i
think
i think odessa yeah she's uh what's
pushing her over the edge she's just
just better at making friends i guess
yeah well you know we all have ourselves
right that's the thing yeah that's great
it makes sense did she make friends with
you fast i mean you guys have a lot of
internships
no we had we had a great time she when
she first came over to london i
we went for walks around regis park we
went to the london zoo oh no we didn't
actually we tried to go to the london
zoo but we couldn't that was my like
pathetic like showing around london was
taken to the zoo who doesn't like the
zoo i know but i mean it's closed
but yeah we go on great and um i hope to
see her soon yeah so in terms of your
relationship on set i know you're
filming a lot of intimate scenes
together
how did you build up that closeness or
that intimacy so that you could do those
scenes on screen you know i actually i
honestly think it's more to do with the
kind of person the kind of actor you're
working with and odessa is um
an incredibly open
actress and and she's all about putting
on to the other and reacting rather than
acting and
she's just about being kind and safe and
generous with your with your
performances and she's got that in
abundance
and now we have ava obviously so ava one
directing those those scenes for you
and your other scenes throughout the
film obviously guiding you through paul
how was working with ava on a film like
oh it's great she you know she had such
a handle of the script and
and knows how to work with actors and
it was just terrific it was the whole
the whole environment on set was really
amazing considering it was
right bang in the middle of covid and
everyone was sort of um
everyone was kind of gathering their
their wits a little bit you know
you make films as a team and
to to look around the crew like you are
now you know everyone's got mars on it's
very strange
so
the fact that ever and
and the team and liz our producer pulled
that all together is really amazing of
course so we have the emmys coming up
you already got the golden globe at home
are we working on a speech are we
polishing one up i think you i think it
has your name on it honestly really okay
i mean i haven't i haven't i haven't
written a speech oh um but i um
i know i will okay so i will write
something because i
the reason i say i know i will is
because i know that
i've like you have to yeah i've learned
of course and so i will write something
and uh we'll see what happens i mean i
honestly look at the category and
they're all like so talented and i love
them all so whoever wins you're all
winners right that's what we say exactly
yeah all right well cheers have a great
night thank you so much